今日,Gigha pay Agents skills 週報25個項目
Gigha 15 個,Kahab 技能 10 個
最高 Microsoft Market 等 16.1 萬 star
上主線,Agents skills 標準化與多平台生態擴張
Microsoft Market 等 16.1 萬 star 月增 3.4 萬
微軟萬能紋盪預處理工具
支持 PDF, Word,PPT,Itself 音飾平等數十種格式一鍵轉mark等
集成 Azure Document in Intelligence 是 LLM 數據管道事實標準,RAD 預處理必備
Hari 0703 Manipreinter Turbo 9.4 萬 star 月增 2.9 萬
AI 短視頻全自動生成 文案到配音字幕 素材剪輯一條龍
支持數平衡平批量輸出 肩融 Deepseek 和同一千萬等國產大模型 自媒體運營首選
Adios Mani Agents skills 6.1 萬 star 月增 1.1 萬
Google Adios Mani 出品的 AI 編碼 Agents 工程化技能級
7個 Slash命令覆蓋開發全生命周期 肩融 Cloud Code,Cursor,Copilot
負質量評估礦價 R&B 替開源
Leonxung Staste Steal 5.3 萬 star 月增 2.7 萬
負於 AI Agents 神媒品味的技能模塊 通過設計系統約束 讓 AI 生成 UI 遠離模板化
對抗 AI Slop 減少同志化輸出
輕量少腳本 安裝即用靈衣賴
Man Hall Last 30 Day Skill 4.7 萬 star 月增 2.1 萬
讓 AI Agents Quarreddit X,YouTube,H&N 等六平台做話題調研 自動篩選交差驗證
輸出結構化摘要 還來源鏈接 和可信度標註 近頻分析力氣
Panelian Tang Agents Reach 4.5 萬 star 月增 2.4 萬
給 AI Agents 裝上全網眼睛 零 API 費用毒取,Twitter,B 站,小紅書等時期的平台
原生 MCP 協議支持 接入 Club Code 和Cursor 突破 Agents 信息減防
Triple T.Jess Hyderon 3.0 萬 star 月增 2.5 萬
Netflix 工程師 出品的 LLM 偷品壓縮神器 內容進大魔型前壓縮 60%-95%
代碼搜索 壓縮92% 三種模式 拍反庫,HTTP代理,MCP服務器
成本直降
SuperMemory i SuperMemory 2.8 萬 star 月增 5193
AI 時代記憶引擎 為 Agents 提供誇會話持久化長期記憶
知識圖譜加上兩件所傷引擎 支持本地全量運行 數據主權歸你
Agent 不再十億
Classio Open Montage 2.7 萬 star 月增 2.2 萬
首個開源 Agents 視頻製作系統 12 條流水線加 52 個工具加 500 個 Agents 技能
AI Agents 自主決策檢及方案 覆蓋劇本到配音權流程
開源免費
Moco 975 and Flowpix Cybersecurity skills 2.3 萬 star 月增 1.1 萬
817 個網絡安全技能 應設 Matter ATT 與CK和 NIST CSF 2.0 等六大安全框架
覆蓋 29 個安全領域 減容 20 個以上平台
安全審計力氣
DS Data Co. Base Memory MCP 1.97 萬 star 月增 1.6 萬
高性能代碼智能 MCP 服務器 毫秒極所引代碼庫 為持久知識圖譜 支持 158 種語言
Token 消耗減少 99% 壓好秒極查詢 0.1 賴部署
Stabby Orca 9802  star 周增 33111
並行 Agents 鍵對管理平台 用你自己的訂閱運行多個編碼 Agents
桌面端家移動端全支持 任務分發和結果聚合
成本透明可控 是核多 Agents 協作場景
Interview Street Hiring Agents 4.020 star 周增 2,266
AI 減力評估與評分 Agents 自動解析減力提取關鍵技能
及於 JD 智能體配度評分
輸出結構劃報告 含優缺點分析 HR 效率工具
Google Agents CLI 4343 star 周增 944
Google 官方 CLI 加技能級 把編程助手訓練成 Agents 部署專家
與 GCP 生態原生集成 支持 Vertex AI Agents Builder
生產級穩定性 企業 GCP 用戶首選
Builder AIO Agents Native 3225 star 周增 1,370
Agent Native應用開發框架
Agent 優先範疇構建 AI 原生應用
Tax Crypt 原生支持 內置工具調度 狀態管理和記憶系統
Builder AIO團隊出品
Capability 以 Wallware 和 Hub 下載 3.6 萬 MetaSkill 原技能
叫 AI Agents 通過結構化自平 發現能力缺口 並自動生成新技能 實現自我進化
Open Cloud 生態核心 下載量斷層第一
Agent 自進化基石
Whackley 和 Hub 下載 1.6 萬 有提了提技能
自然與言驅動命令型交互 將日常需求翻譯為善命令 自帶教驗與回滾
命令執行前 教驗加失敗自動回滾 開發者日常效率工具
Bud Rover 和 Hub 下載 1.6 萬 有提了提技能
自主文件系統探索引擎 自動導航幕錄結構 總結代碼庫 構建項目架構上下文
無需指定目標文件 自動便利理解代碼庫 新人上手立起
self in proven agent 和 Hub 下載 1.6 萬  MetaSkill 原技能
專注 prompt 自我經驗
Agent 分析輸出質量 發現指令不清之處 並重寫 scale MD
自動檢測缺陷 分析跟音 必緩改進
ATXP 和 Hub 下載 1.4 萬 有提了提技能
結構化任務執行追蹤器 將複雜請求 拆解為子任務 追蹤完成狀態 跨中段保持上下文
Agent 內置項目管理 長流程自動化引擎
Google Workspace 全集技能 和 Hub 下載 1.4 萬
一個技能覆蓋 Dox, Sheets, Slides, Drive, Calendar 只沒有全家筒
官方 API 認證多端同步 辦公自動化和文檔寫作必備
Agent Browser 和 Hub 下載 1.2 萬 嬰恕技能
流覽器自動化技能Agent 像人類一樣流覽網頁 填寫表單 提取內容
視覺加 DOAM 商程教業, PlayRide 驅動穩定可靠
Samarice 和 Hub 下載 1.1 萬 有提了提技能
帝規摘要技能 將文檔 URL 對話歷史 代碼等任意輸入 轉為結構化摘要
超常文檔自動分辨帝規摘要 信息壓縮和知識提取好幫手
Gig Hub 和 Hub 下載 1.1 萬 嬰恕技能
Gig Hub 全功能集成 倉庫管理 醫術和 P2 自動化 代碼審查和工作流編排
深度集成 P2 自動化流 開發者 Agent 必備連接器
Tallly Web Search 和 Hub 下載 8.142 嬰恕技能
與一級網頁搜索技能 通過Tallly API 實現比關鍵詞更精準的 RAD 有好減鎖
內置 HTMBILE 降噪 輸出 RAD 有好格式
三大信號 Agent Steels 標準化爆發
從 Agent Steels 到 Cyber Security Steels 技能成 Agent 通用語言
多平台生態擴張 Agent Reach 覆蓋時期平台
可 Hub 原技能 下